You might see the world in terms of black
and white, but HOW black and HOW white?
Howdy friends, Trace here for DNews, thanks
for tuning in!
You probably remember from grade school that
black paint is a mixture of all the colors…
red, yellow, blue, green, orange, and purple
equals black.
White paint though, is a little more technical.
It's made using a variety of natural materials
like chalk or lime dust mixed with viscous
liquid.
But the mistake comes when assuming we've
made the whitest white or the blackest black
around -- we haven't!
Until now.
The scales of the cyphochilus beetle from
South-East Asia reflect more light than a
piece of white paper due to specialized ultra-thin
scales that cover its beetley-body.
In fact, according to research in Scientific
Reports, this beetle is the whitest thing
in nature!
The beetle's scales are made of chitin -- found
throughout the animal kingdom in exoskeletons
and shells, it's similar to cellulose.
The chitin scales are only a few nanometers
thick, which is beyond our comprehension to
make.
They're so complex, they reflect the maximum
amount of white with the most minimum material!
Thin and light is important for flying insects,
but difficult for manufacturing, for now.
Exploring these scales might help humans make
a biomimetic copy, creating brighter papers,
plastics, paints and more reflective display
materials for computing making more with less!
Light reflection and absorption is big business
in space technology too.
Black paint is black because it absorbs all
the light shone on it.
Most black paint isn't very good, reflecting
about two and a half percent of the light
shone on it, but SUPER black materials, they
reflect only half-a-percent of light, or less!!
IT'S SO BLACK!
It reflects so much light that you can't even
SEE it when it's folded!
Look at this pictur[a][b]e, see those four
rectangles that look like holes in the frame?
THAT'S CALLED "SUPER BLACK!"
I know it sounds like a 1970s film, but it's
not…
Super black is so dark that even in this well-lit
photo it just looks like a hole!
It's made of carbon nanotubes arranged on
an adhesive material and titanium, ideal for
use in space; again it's lightweight and strong,
not unlike chitin.
The tubes are a few nanometers in diameter,
and are grown in an arrangement sort of like
a shag carpet.
The web of tiny nanotubes traps light absorbing
10 times the energy of their normal black
coating.
NASA created the material for use in the space
program to coat cameras and absorb stray light
that can bounce off the satellite and mess
up cameras or other optics.
Sometimes, the source of light in space is
so faint, any unwanted light can mess up a
whole mission!
They've sent it to the ISS for testing -- space
is pretty harsh with the temperature changes,
radiation and energy particles -- but if it
performs well, they'll use it for future sensor
missions.
As technology improves, the whitest and blackest
materials are getting better by tiny fractions,
but each step can provide a benefit in any
number of industries!
There's already a company in the UK that's
created something even BLACKER than SUPER
BLACK!
What do you think of technology like this?
Awesome or a waste of time?
Tell me what you think down below, subscribe
to DNews and while you're dealing out your
opinions, check out my new show TestTube!
In this episode we're exploring the politics
of why the US and China are competing over
Africa.
It's SUPER interesting.
To tell me what you think of the show, find
me on twitter at-TraceDominguez.